foreign
let's go to Andrew in Traverse City one
of my favorite places on the planet
what's up Andrew
hey John how you doing man excellent
excellent man I got some family in
Traverse City what an amazing amazing
place
yeah it's great I'm shivering though
it's a little cold already we actually
got some snow in some places Northern
Michigan today so a little early for
that wow well congratulations it's 111
degrees here in Nashville today so
yeah rub it in uh so what's up man
all right John I'm hoping for your
opinion on a health and kind of mental
health related eating and diet question
um I just really need some help figuring
out why I'm struggling craving like
super unhealthy Foods way too often
right now okay um and then kind of how I
put some boundaries in place for myself
around that excellent what's up
all right so I got a three-month-old
baby so I'm a little tired makes sense
uh a boy girl
it is a little boy can we just stop for
a minute congrats man thanks man it's
our first really excited about it's all
going okay perfect perfect perfect okay
so uh first three months in you don't
know what day it is and you it's like
Rocky IV and he's like hit the one in
the middle like you're just exhausted
all the time and uh okay
all right so here's some details I'm I'm
generally a healthy pretty active person
I'd say I eat you know I eat healthy at
home but lately um maybe the past couple
years I've just kind of been tuning into
it a little more I've been struggling
with like just wanting to eat unhealthy
and then eating out like unhealthy like
way too often now way too often is my
opinion but we'll get to that you know
I've noticed a pattern of you know when
I'm stressed or anxious I'm craving like
specifically like fast food oh yeah you
know yeah exactly exactly so the first
thing is again I'm wondering if you can
help me figure out why that is
um but also you know if you can give me
some boundaries you'd recommend around
cheat meals I've heard you talk about
cheat meals and different things but I
feel like I just have an unhealthy view
of food right now sure um and it's super
bothering me man absolutely well thanks
for calling it out and um man this takes
a level of introspection and what I mean
by that this is for all new parents
um or all parents going through
particular life transitions with with
themselves their spouse and their kids
um
noticing hey I've started engaging in
unhealthy Behavior I had this
conversation the other night with myself
about uh social media again I've I've
gotten sucked back into the Vortex and I
was like man I'm just staring at this
thing all day
um and so good for you man for noticing
I am headed down a trail that I don't
want to be I don't want to go down
um all right so I'm gonna give you what
the science says so I can do one up on
my on my opinion and I'm actually going
to throw out a hypothesis that I have
that I've not confirmed scientifically I
don't know that it matters but it makes
sense to me and if any of nutrition
folks actually know the science here I'd
love for you to leave comments uh on
YouTube or shoot me a direct message
um so there is plenty of studies a
number of studies that show when we get
tired
We crave carbohydrates especially sugary
Foods
there's also studies that show when we
are stressed
when the stress cycle has kicked off We
crave sugary carbohydrate-laden Foods
also the Savory the salt and the
fats that drip off a Big Mac
see now you've got me thinking about
fast food and so you craving fast food
right now is your whole life has been
dumped upside down not to mention not
just the baby but let's let's back up
man things have been Wild for the last
year right you found out you're pregnant
you had I mean the whole the whole world
it's been ramping and ramping and
ramping for sure um and then suddenly it
happens and you're like it's going to be
like this and it's nothing like you
thought it was going to be is it
no not at all you thought they only
pooped twice a day no exactly a thousand
a thousand times a day
um so anyway everything's in
everything's in flux here's so that's
the science so I tell you that to tell
you you're not crazy in fact you are
right in the middle of the bell curve
normal okay you're exhausted you're
stressed you and your wife are having to
navigate a new relationship so you're
married to a new person right now and so
is she
okay I want you to think about it that
that it's that different now
um you have a new variable in your home
you've got new expenses so you've gotten
Financial stress you like you know
you've probably already done the
calculation so if Putin actually invades
Ukraine full-on or launches a nuke it
would be this many years until right
until the draft I mean you've probably
already done those calculations like
every parent has
it's a mess it's a mess my here's my
hypothesis okay
um I think one of two things
when they're fight or flight system
kicks off it actually pulls blood away
from the digestive system and and sends
it to them our muscles
okay we don't need to be eating and
digesting food we are fighting or
fleeing for our lives okay that's just
how our stress response system works
the cheapest quickest forms of calories
or energy so remember our bodies in
fight or flight assume we are fighting
something or running from something
it craves the simplest calories you can
get which is a cheap simple carbohydrate
the problem is
we're not running or fighting anything
we're just sitting in traffic or dealing
with emails or changing another diaper
right and our stress system is saying we
need more energy we don't really we
don't really because we're just sitting
there
and man there are sugary cheap calories
everywhere and now they'll just deliver
my to your house you don't even have to
move you don't even have to have real
money you can just push a button on your
phone and ah it just shows up you see
what I'm saying like so we now live in a
world that your body was not designed to
live in
so I think that our again this is total
speculation this is just the story I've
told myself I think the fight-or-flight
systems activation
would if I'm running for my life I'm in
the middle of a long protracted fight
grabbing something like a piece of fruit
grab me some sugar in my body 5000 years
ago would give me a sudden burst of
quick energy that would not take a lot
of digestive energy and would allow me
to get back in the fight
amen a Twinkie is like a super version
of that right or an Arby's sandwich or
french fries french fries
um for sure the other idea I have is
this happened last night I'm writing a
new book it was midnight I had I had
chapters due last night
um
I'm out of energy I'm out of gas and I
found myself down there I grabbed a
protein bar but it's one of those
protein bars that are really like
Snickers bars they just shove protein in
it and they trick you into I mean they
lie to you and you go along with the LIE
there's some sort of health food when
it's really not it was one of those kind
of bars I feel like the sugar was a
quick energy boost for a body that was
so taxed on sleep I'm just exhausted
right now
um and so since I don't have my normal
rest my body is going to go for some
cheap explosive energy really fast to
try to prop me up until I can get to
sleep again that's my hypothesis there I
don't know if that's accurate I don't
know that it matters what what does
matter is the science says when you're
exhausted the science says when you're
stressed we reach for trash and we eat
we overeat to we eat more trash than
normal okay oh for sure so what do you
what have you tried to do to to head
this off at the pass
well I mean it's gotten worse since you
know my little guy was born three months
ago and I think you're right on with
that hypothesis
um but you know the things I've tried
have been just like you know saying like
you know no ahead of time and like you
know taking different routes home and
like bringing extra food to work and it
feels like the issue I'm dealing with
you know again I mentioned I've noticed
it start over the last couple years of
course it gets it's gotten exacerbated
by you know my baby is like I'll come
out of like a really tough work meeting
or a really tough case or something like
that and it's like man if I just like go
park somewhere and eat some fast food
I'll like be able to take a breather and
like that dopamine or I'm not sure what
exactly it is will hit and I'll just
feel better and I'll drive away and then
that was a kid I'm like how this pattern
is not good for me so you know I'm not
really answering the question but I
haven't tried many specific things I was
kind of hoping you could help me with
that yeah okay so you nailed it
it's the if I just statement
okay so the nerd were in the nerd World
here's what we're looking for we're
looking for The Gap
the gap between stressful meeting
and the thought that follows which is I
just need to get some satiating food and
then I'll feel better
you need the gap between stimulus and
response stressful meeting Big Mac
frustrating interaction with my wife bag
of Gummy candies screaming kid I'm just
gonna go grab a pizza we don't need to
we don't need to eat here tonight
because you know on the back end
dopamine is about motivation it's
actually not about pleasure even I've
been wrong on this Andy huberman has
done a great job uh explaining this but
there's no such thing like dopamine hits
that's not really how that works
dopamine is a molecule of motivation and
the moment the ball gets rolled down the
hill
um think of it this way like a
teeter-totter the moment it's that it
sits down and begins to the other end it
starts to go up on the teeter-totter you
know dopamine gets the lever gets pushed
towards pleasure
as soon as you bite into that Arby
sandwich or into that piece of pizza
your body has to has to flatten out that
uh teeter-totter and it has one way of
doing it pain
that's why you feel ashamed that's why
you feel bad that's why you feel
because it's gotta hit the other end of
the of it it's got to hit the other end
of the Teeter Totter so here's what
we're gonna do we're going to opt out of
the system completely because you know
it's not true
if I can just go get something to eat it
will make this last meeting feel better
that's a false statement it's a lie it's
not true
and so you've heard me on this show say
demand evidence
ask yourself what is my body trying to
protect me from
identify the behavior for me it's it's
trash eating too it used to be calling
old friends it used to be checking it
whatever your behavior is that you want
to stop right before you do it
ask yourself what is my body trying to
protect me from
some people text old girlfriends some
people grab another drink and then
another drink some people just pick out
their phone and start scrolling some
people roll up to a pornography website
whatever
ask yourself as you're entering into
this Behavior you don't want to do what
is my body trying to protect me from oh
I had a crappy meeting
makes me feel like I'm gonna get fired
and then here's the magic words we're
going to demand evidence am I gonna get
fired no
or am I gonna get fired yeah if I don't
make another sale I'm gonna get fired I
should probably look for another job
right or I should probably start getting
on the phone right so we can solve that
problem with actual things
um actual actions are gonna work
but an Arby's sandwich has never solved
anything it just hasn't
right is that fair
yeah it is fair it makes sense and I
think you're on it more tactically
I've had Seasons where I took my debit
card out of my wallet and gave it to my
wife
well yeah delete all apps off your phone
when you're trying to change an
addictive habit you have to create
systems that allow you to be successful
all the junk has to be out of the house
I don't have like I don't have access to
money I just can't go I can't stop there
and you're gonna run out of gas at one
point it's gonna be super annoying and
we're playing a long game with your
health it's worth the it's worth the
exchange
but in this early stage that's why if
you're an alcoholic and you're
struggling with alcohol you you got to
dump everything down the sink you got to
get out of your house start day one
you have to get stop hanging out with
people who go to bars day too right you
got to make some radical life movements
uh life changes you do too you're gonna
have to practice new coping behaviors
it may be after a hard meeting I'm gonna
go for a walk
maybe after a hard meeting I'm going to
call a friend maybe after a hard beating
I'm gonna pull out a journal that I got
for like eight bucks you know at
Walgreens and I'm gonna write down
here's what I felt in that last meeting
we're going to practice new copings on
the way home I'm just going to swing by
the gym for 15 minutes and do a 15
minute workout that's it
see what I'm saying we're building in
things along the way that are going to
become new habits for us to start yeah
but you got to go scorched Earth on the
prevention side
okay I am not I'm somebody and I've
learned this the hard way
I can't do moderation or let me put it
this way I'm choosing for that not to be
a battle that I fight I've got too many
other battles internally that I'm trying
to trying to deal with so I have to say
no
I've got to I can't have
some fast food sometime I just I I just
I don't I just have to walk away from it
if I do have it I'm going all in man I'm
gonna get super sized I'm gonna get five
fries I'm gonna get two virgins I mean
I'm going all in
um and I've made peace with that too
that's okay I just do it so rarely now
okay this weekend me and my son went and
got a hotel we went on like a little
father-son hunting trip dude I ate
myself into a coma it was awesome and
because I'm playing a long game here we
had fun we're making memories being
silly and I was back on the wagon this
morning okay
um you're not there yet
here's what I'm worried about that food
is becoming medication for you is that
right
I I think that's 100 accurate yeah
that's what I called did you learn that
at home is this new where'd you pick
that up from
I don't know and uh my mom had cancer
when I was four and she had like all
these different doctors having her on
these like fad diets so that she
wouldn't they wouldn't come back and I
knew you're gonna ask me that question I
was like do I even bring that up or not
I don't know if that's accurate or not
absolutely man listen listen how that's
encoded in your body
but somehow food is the solution to fill
in the blank
is your mom still with you
yeah she she made it yeah man food
solves everything
and intellectually you know that's
insane
and it's not that insane healthy eating
is really good for you right and it's
preventative in a number of different
areas
um
but that's particularly encoded in your
body
food will solve this
it's just become very perverted and now
it's food makes me feel better
and then food makes me uh or I I I
overeat and then I feel ashamed and then
I want to hide and then the whole thing
starts over again
and so I'm not telling you to get a
phobia about food I'm not telling you to
head down a disorder eating track or
anything like that I'm just suggesting
that you create systems of the person
you want to become I want to become a
guy who's a good Steward of his body I'm
going to create an identity that way and
then I'm going to create habits that
make that happen
I'm a guy that I need that garbage
even this morning
um my new friend Jade warshaw here she
was had made these incredible vegan
whatever Kumbaya muffins that I think
they did yoga over them I don't know
they were awesome and they were dusted
with essential oils or something she
walked by and she said oh you don't eat
sweets
like that's an identity I have around
the office and I said okay oh but today
I will because they just look delicious
and so
um
but are you making a conscious choice to
step off the wagon at that point and
you're able at this point you're you're
where you can step right back on yes and
it's been years it's been years okay
and I also know often when I step back
on when I step off the wagon
intentionally uh that's that's one of my
that's my one of my internal mantras I'm
a guy who doesn't fall off the wagon but
I will step off the wagon and roll
around in the mud every once in a while
and then I'll climb back up and I
usually slip off the wagon four or five
times trying to get back on and then I
get back on the wagon but that's an
identity I have I'm a guy that didn't
fall off the wagon and that means uh I
have to be really conscious of when I'm
exhausted
really conscious of when I'm stressed
out
so I'm it like I mentioned a couple
times I'm writing a new book right now I
started a
uh new exercise program and a new eating
regimen
about a month out of this process
so that when I hit this thing I'd be
ready to rock and roll I wouldn't have
to also be fighting my exercise routine
and my diet routine does that make sense
yes that's just me trying to be
intentional because I've lost I've
failed it every time and all my other
writing projects dude I end up just a
goofy Mess by the time it's all over and
I I'm just tired of reclaiming my life
every time so this time my identity is
I'm a guy that takes care of himself and
who's going to take care of himself
through this entire stressful process
that's just where you are and so if you
think about it I want to create an
identity
I want to be this kind of Dad I'm a dad
who's a good Steward of his one body I'm
gonna teach my kids what that looks like
and while I learned that I can't have
any cash in my wallet because I'll go
I'll go to fast food
that makes sense it makes a hundred
percent sense yeah thank you and by the
way
you don't suck and you're not a loser
and you're not a failure you're a
first-time dad
you've never done this before this is
new
and you're pretty young and so this is
probably your first or second big job
and this is your first time dealing with
what you know adult stress this is your
first time being married to somebody who
just had a kid
this is your first time not sleeping for
months on end all these things are new
so cut yourself some slack you are way
ahead of the game man you woke up three
months in you're like whoa that's a lot
of Burger King
I should probably put the burrito down
and back the thing up
good for you man that's awesome
let's focus on identities first not
goals let's focus on who we're going to
become and this is a great exercise for
you and your wife too
um let's focus on who we're gonna become
and then let's reverse engineer that
with a series of behaviors
and food's not the enemy fast food's not
the enemy
um sugar isn't I'm not going to war over
sugar anymore I'm just not I got too
much other stuff to do
I'm going to be about the things that I
can positively impact because that's the
kind of guy I want to be
the kind of guy you want to be
and you'll get there man thank you so
much for your call holler back as you
make this uh as you make this turn and
I'll be willing to walk with you every
step of the way thank you brother Andrew
congratulations on your little boy